hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembered so you don't have to sarah
palin is stupid then I got my Sarah
Palin joke out of the way let's talk
about Alaska now I've been to Alaska
before it has great views great culture
and great people but if you were to
judge it by watching this movie you'd
say it had great views found in culture
and horrible people this film would be a
great promotional tool for the state if
they just eradicated everything
breathing from it the stories beyond
unrealistic the characters are cartoons
of cartoons it's just an all-around mess
so let's see what the polar icecaps have
farted at us this time this is Alaska so
it's a crash role we see a pilot flying
his plane across Alaska you can probably
tell by the music that they're pretty
desperate to make any scene sound epic
and whimsical even when nothing's
happening yet okey doke partner this is
what's your service
clear and of course we get our first
look at our cuddly little co-star oh oh
Bluebird bears are so cute aren't they
cause the way the music makes them sound
they just seem so innocent and cut got a
mess there's a kitchen
oh Jesus Christ they're horrible being
so what demonic creatures can possibly
always the door bitches wanna play in
the eyes if this was nothing about
metallics there's I got a killer don't
stop it nothing here
well it turns out the nasty evil poacher
was to hunt adorable cookies
he's played by Charlton nope I'm not
making a plan of leaves joke in this
review Heston magnificent creature the
polar bear
nature's perfect carnival adapted to the
most hostile climate on earth now boy
looks like we have another killer slash
poet on our hands these are the a-holes
that can never just pull the trigger
they always have to make a great big
speech before they do anything yeah he
probably talks this way while looking
through the adult section at a video
store magnificent filled boobie
slaughters 28 adapted to even the most
hostile perverted wrinkled bags like
myself I'll pay with credit magnificent
car the visa platinum card feels like 10
or 20 grand just your skill I love this
gun huh your problem mr. Kocis that you
don't appreciate the finer things in
life
that's true he doesn't appreciate the
finer things in life like killing a good
chunk of those finer things in life
so the mother is shot and the baby is
kidnapped while we cut to one of our
main characters of the film named Jesse
played by Thora Birch oh my god I'm late
late for what
hey girls always a nerd I've heard
Dumber things to find whimsical she
communicates often with her father the
pilot but sadly her brother Shawn it's
not quite as into the Alaskan spirit
you're really helping like I had that's
a big negative matter to go where is he
you know just being that Alaskan
mountain man we know and love Wow who
went down on whom to get this game in
this movie I mean this game wasn't even
popular when ever so he hangs out in a
store with the owner and his pet eagle
where he often asked if there's any
messages from his old home in Chicago uh
can you just sort out an email from
Chicago
you were stare you know great fires of
1935 up the Yukon River just asking for
the mail I was a very young man hunting
alone the forest fire jumped too rich I
see a weather front explains there then
I looked up to the smoke I saw Eagle
does he deliver mail faster than you
something said to me just the eagle flew
through the smoke and I followed you
know the Eagle is also symbol of the
post-office they give me my mail you
fucking old man just kept looking at the
Eagle sky juergen fire was behind me all
this time I thought you were my torna
tauranac my spirit guide yeah well my
turn AK is my fist that's telling me to
collide very harshly with your face give
me my mail look you have any mail for me
or not sorry Sean not today but would
you like to hear how my hamster is my
spiritual financial adviser
so Shauna's bummed out because not only
does he miss Chicago but he misses the
fact that his mother died due to I don't
know pick what I got you guys something
up and no thanks dad
gee thanks dad a compass what am I
supposed to do with a compass trip and I
went sea kayaking early eight miles up
the coast today excuse me while I call
CNN oh and by the way he's a dick in
this movie maybe I'll buy myself a
one-way ticket back to Chicago I don't
have time for this now
mom would've had time none of us would
be having if she was still here none of
this but Sean she's not here yeah well I
wish you had died not her okay this shit
really pisses me off losing a parent is
a serious thing before Disney turned
into a common fad but even then they at
least tried to play to how hard it can
be in a semi plausible manner here it's
just a means to an end a plot device and
it's way too rushed and way too
over-the-top we just find out in this
scene that their mom is dead and that's
the line that follows our discovery of
it
there's no lead-up no segue no trying to
understand what he's going through just
the line I wish you had died not her and
I hope you choke on your testicles you
live a pre-course yeah I hate him and
there's no way you can make me like him
I don't care if he cures cancer I'm
still not gonna enjoy his character that
was so mean-spirited and so out of
nowhere that I hope he just
spontaneously combust when he goes into
that room well I wish you had died not
her and nobody will miss him next oh
wait just when you think this movie this
family movie might you couldn't possibly
get any more mean-spirited take a look
at what the poachers are doing with the
mother and son
oh Jesus all right wouldn't you mMmmm
Sheamus separate a mother and child
isn't it okay be on sick I mean that is
fucking demented it is sick then it's
just so fucking sick so doing a funny
little puppet show at your great aunt's
funeral where's your great aunt I mean
for God's sakes that's the mother's
corpse not even of course the skill of
the courts with the head still attached
you know there's been mean in a movie
and then as being the devil this is
being the devil's devil the devil the
devil goes to when the devil's not being
devilish enough what's this read it
doesn't matter baby oh by anybody so the
son gets half of his wish to come true
as the father disappears in a plane
crash
but then he discovers maybe wishing
death to those who gave him life wasn't
such a nice thing to do so he bugs the
police endlessly until they track him
down nothing but rocks and snow on devil
stuff he has to be out there they're
just not looking hard enough
why don't you guys take another pass
just to be sure we're getting low on you
look give it another search and rescues
made three trips now you saw that
oh come on peeps seriously telling me
they can't see that you're honestly
saying that the rescue crew but the
people who specialize in doing this
can't see a banana color plane on the
edge of a mountain on their third time
around look at this practically in the
same frame the same frame just turn your
head to the fucking right and you'll see
the goddamn thing well hell the guy has
flares that should be able to get their
attention right
oh fuck you movie fuck you seen better
eyesight on mr. Magoo's vision test what
the hell's wrong with these people this
is the worst rescue ever imagine these
idiots actually went on flexion you see
how well that would go can you see
anything Frank no nothing but sky a nose
as far as the eye can see what if you
turn your head around not gonna do
something stupid like that okay we best
that back yeah you hear something what
you need that blood roving screen ya
know so after the rescue team says dude
we no see you're dead Sean decides he's
gonna go up into the mountains himself
and find out where he is but Jesse
brings up a very good point that he
doesn't know anything about mountain
climbing at all because he is a complete
dumbass
well this is stuff which might actually
be useful I tried to find dad like a Mac
we're gonna do swim to Devil's Thumb you
got a better idea of course I do
oh you mean like go to an adult get a
climbing team to assist you go buy your
fucking stupid little selves like it's a
goddamn camping trip oh yeah this was
obviously the logical choice
you
wasn't even a big thing it took them
like a minute to come to this
life-threatening conclusion that could
doom them forever but hey on the bright
side maybe one can finally see some
interaction between these two after all
they are brother and sister and they
barely said a word to each other since
the move or are they just battle big
waves don't develop any care for
building relationships or anything
Alaska wants to encourage people to go
kayaking freeze to death so what's the
big deal we'll make a fire good I hope
you brought the match I can't believe
you're dumb enough to forget the matches
it's almost as if this was a brain
numbing least stupid idea but what a
coincidence they just happen to come
across the camping ground of the
poachers as well as the trapped baby
polar bear we can't just leave her here
that's her mother hang neither so they
let her go and keep heading on their way
which makes big bad Heston mad I don't
think you understand me let me be clear
I'm accustomed to getting what I want I
want that bear yes just like officer
surveyor in lanier zaraba de lieutenant
Gerard from the fugitive or Captain Ahab
from Moby Dick Charlton Heston is
obsessed with capturing a cute cuddly
little polar bear and his character is
so deep and so complex that I can talk
for hours about why he obsesses over his
capture because he can say the word bear
really cool
but the pair
seems to be following the kids and
disappointingly is not out to eat them
but then Heston comes along and the bear
for being a little baby really seems to
know how to stand still and be quiet
when the villains are around my my
grandma what big teeth you got your dog
a bear Bennett bear bear right before my
dad shot it
dad shot a bear for biting his Pam for
interrupting his dinner so well they
don't necessarily believe the kids story
they also don't believe that they're
stealing the bear for themselves either
so they decide to leave them alone
but then when they discover that the
bear is following them they decide it
might not be good to let on that they
know where they're heading to the
authorities I'm looking for a couple of
kids boy and girl who may have headed
out this way have you seen him they were
brought up on MTV and video games they
know nothing of the real world they
can't conceive of the true brutality of
nature
so is that up no or what he didn't even
answer his question does he have to
describe everything he sees with a
poetic edge give me great for selling
products on TV when he color the same of
a golden sunrise gold and crisp gives
you that satisfying taste that booming
God's good pure earth can give you plus
it's represented by
bear meanwhile the two kids continue to
travel up the mountain oh please tell me
this results in another spinning shot
with a choir thrown in for no reason
but then Sean falls down the mountain
and bumps his head on a rock resulting
in a half assed dream sequence
door knob so it turns out the bear is
his turning which makes no sense see how
Jessie is more trained in the ways of
staying alive in the wilderness so
clearly she should be given the cool pet
spiritual guide but what uh what take a
bite out of me it's not a see anyhow
it's a he trust me I got a very good
look the only thing more dangerous than
hunting bears is hunting pebbles yeah I
don't know exactly where the good look
at bear ball scene was but uh I'm glad I
missed it so while the dad I'm sure is
becoming a permanent part of the Alaska
tour antaraya right is are rotting carbs
the kids go rowing through the rapids
again because you know we haven't seen
that yet and Shawn ends up almost
drowning
but amazing coincidence number two they
come across the store owner and his son
and it turns out the owner he's actually
cool with them risking their lives like
morons
I can't go back kids have no
appreciation for this country that's why
they need to go if my father's time a
young man had to hunt up there with only
a spear in his hand
and so take on a bear's power died
trying again it's the die trying part
that causes concern these two are on a
spirit journey they've gone too far and
be wrong for us to stop them now Wow
that spirit journey stuff really seems
too little a fly with this guy doesn't
dad I'm off to put feces in the brownie
sundae of the teacher I don't like well
I don't know if I have spirit at all are
you finished dad
their spirit journey has come to an end
this is the nineties old man get home
first thing in the morning again don't
you just love the realistic father-son
talks in this movie yeah you can just
feel the connection like they'd known
each other for years this is the 90s old
man I remember the last time I said that
to my dad they really want the last time
but the store owners grandson decides to
help them out anyway because they seem
too passionate about their journey yeah
if there's a passionate about how come
they didn't sneak out in the middle of
the night while nobody was looking a
white bear over there tearing it I'd say
he's looking out for you something Shawn
you can only see by opening yard by the
way I find it hard to believe that the
father isn't woken up by all this coming
snooze a look out for more food Shawn
trust a bear so despite the fact that
everything points to going one direction
Shawn decides he wants to go another why
we have to trust bear
that's right we need to trust the bear
trust him to lead right to the bad guys
get shot by a dart and get carried away
so you can't follow him anymore your
spirit journey is taking a bit of a
rocky detour isn't it otherwise hi time
for a game of disappearing bears the
bear starts to wake up and begins
fighting them all which leads to a
humorous way and how these guys give
beep just when the bear is about to be
shot he bites them to you it forces him
to shoot the guy which forces him to
shoot the helicopter which forces the
controls to explode that word the cat
who ate the rat that lived in the house
that Jack built
now get kudos that's a funny way to go
direct oh I shot myself in the foot like
a Michael Moore interview he's alive so
the kids finally find the father and
attempt to pull him up unfortunately
though hidden and Shawn are too heavy
for Jesse to hold on to what are they
possibly gonna do
bullshit oh come by no no doesn't happen
I know he's not even pulling the rope
he's just playing with it fucking long
you guys ain't gonna believe this Jesse
found him okay I think we all know the
news story is gonna read the next day
professional rescue team searches three
times and helicopter and doesn't find
giant yellow colored plant two little
kids on foot go once and find them
without any aviation help whatsoever
I don't think Alaskan Authority looks
very good in this movie so that's Alaska
and boy is it a real piece of work
the plot is outlandish the kids would
have been Bear Chow in seconds the
gun-toting maniac plays the gun-toting
maniac but worst of all it's the lack of
any interesting interaction that really
sinks it maybe if it was just about a
family in Alaska dealing with the loss
of their mother while traveling in the
mountains that would have been fine that
actually would have been interesting if
it was done right but they make no
attempts to have these people talk to
each other like their family at all the
brother and sister almost never speak
the mean spirited boy is just way too
rotten the father is forget ibly bland
and they never take the time to show how
what they're going through is affecting
it's just set up for standard boring
action scenes yeah
Alaska looks nice but it's not worth
sitting through this rotten story to see
it all I gotta say is I want that bear
do this to this movie I'm gonna stash a
credit guy remember it so you don't have
to
I want that bear